nowhere is this better exemplified then
in the recent special of the alleged
comedian Michelle wolf you'll remember
her she was at the White House
Correspondents Dinner a few years ago
and she made fun of Sarah Sanders and
this was something of a controversy
so Michelle Wolf's got a new special on
Netflix and she decided to do a whole
bit a whole joke about how killing her
child made her feel like God here she is
so negatively that you feel like you
should have this sense of shame after
you get an abortion
well you can feel any way you want after
you get an abortion get one see how you
feel you know my abortion made me feel
very powerful you know people say you
can't play God
[Music]
[Applause]
morgan freeman you know that's pretty
ghastly I think it's pretty repugnant
most people are so shocked by that joke
because it's so real it's so true it's
actually why it's a it's a pretty good
joke if not for all the suffering if not
for all the dead babies if not for the
reality of it because she actually
killed her child it would be a very
funny joke
if not for the victims why would it be a
funny joke because it's so true she's
right
I'm sure she did feel very powerful the
ability to snuff out innocent life makes
one feel powerful it makes one take on
the presumed to have the authority of
God yeah that she's right that's not a
good thing that's a very bad thing the
impulse of radical egalitarian democracy
is to make each man a god that's the
trouble and what is the result of that
is the result of that a good thriving
wonderful society where we all love each
other and we're all very nice to each
other no the result of that is a society
that is coarse and capricious and
miserable and murderous hey Michael
Knowles here and the fact is these
cigars aren't cheap be sure to subscribe
to The Daily wire on YouTube because I
depend heavily on your support to
continue enjoying this wonderful Lib
triggering life